how's it going bros my name is P ball
today's video might seem a little mean
but it was requested by you Burris now
some would say that these pictures are
not up to standard but I'm here to say
no they are perfect the way they are so
I'm gonna take the original photo and
changed it to the fan art so it matches
that's how good of a person I am that's
how much I love my fans if people don't
realize this by now oh man first picture
is the classic brofist where is it I
swear I've seen this [ __ ] picture
okay I'm gonna ask Twitter for the
original to this fan art and see if they
can find for [ __ ] sake oh here it is
okay it must be this one why do I look
so fat in this picture was like fat
before alright so here's this one let's
fix it up so clearly my eyes are
disportionateately large
okay the forehead needs to be adjusted
like I knew my forehead was big but I
didn't know I guess I never realized how
big it actually is because that's
therefore it is something
they line up perfectly oh that's good
look at that it's all it's like almost
hundred percent it's 100% accurate fan
art and I really appreciate the talent
[ __ ] the haters now here's another great
great one listen I am NOT stomping over
you Bros to the art I am just trying to
correct now the tricky part about this
picture is that it's it's kind of hard
to tell where the original is from but I
do believe it's from Ender's Game and I
think it's this pissed picture for some
fucked-up reason the photographer
messed up my face this is how it looked
like so let's let's adjust it to the
original you know what that's [ __ ]
good nothing needed I am seriously
thinking the guy or girl printed out the
picture and overlaid it you know when
you put the picture towards a window and
you can just fill it in this proportions
are a little too perfect for me to think
they didn't just do that and my nose my
nose is spot on
honestly like I appreciate that okay
well let's fix this [ __ ] I need to get
into plastic surgery soon
all right so let's have a look before
ask if you have disgusting disfigured
face beautiful for Who I am
thank you fan art all right let's see
what your us think about this one it
just kind of looked like Donald Trump
what the [ __ ]
same person yeah well no [ __ ] Sherlock
dude this guy looks like he wants to do
something horrible to me oh my god yes
let's finish it off with the greatest
picture I have ever seen I can't draw
for shape I'm not trying to put anyone
down here original to this pic it
matches perfectly [ __ ] sake
not funny here we go here's the original
clearly someone try to prank me and did
something weird with a picture oh god
this is gonna be tricky man honestly the
nose is spot-on I don't even have to
change it my poor nose everyone makes
fun of it my whole life what I do Jesus
Christ this is [ __ ] terrifying dude
this is art like this is art you can't
argue with art I love it so much
Oh disgusting I feel like I'm doing you
bros a favor here I don't know would you
agree Dan agrees what the [ __ ] why do I
have this picture all right let's see if
you bros agree with me your teeth goals
thanks net mates do come true Felix have
to crack how did you know the [ __ ] come
on it's good alright price you bros are
amazing i love everything you do for me
there's so much talent and even though i
appreciate the effort alright the funny
part about this picture is i still look
the same
like they're practically still identical
i love this picture i will forever
cherish his picture gross thank you so
much for watching this video and thank
you so much for all the amazing fan art
I really really really appreciate the
effort I think it's really cool I hope
you didn't take this the wrong way thank
you both so much for watching and as
always stay awesome
I feel like this one is really a winner
guys it applies to both men and women